[Musica]
buonasera a tutti
forse qualcuno di voi ha visto che è
murato gli aeroplanini siete vedete
tutti dietro alla 6 delle vetrine notati
bene sono quello degli aeroplanini però
li usiamo all'ultimo minuto
il tempo dove ragazzi alla 14 45 io vi
devo dire una cosa che dura poco il
resto me lo invento anche perché il
racconto che li faccio e arriva a da
quella frase la che avevo detto aperte
per ridere sostanzialmente lei non sa
chi sono io l'ho senza dire una volta in
vita mia
in realtà l'ho detta perché è il dopo
che è interessante lei non sa chi sono
io e non lo so nemmeno io e tutta lì
allora è il racconto di un minuto della
mia vita proprio un momento un momento
nel senso che è durato pochissimo
un'intuizione un pensiero che è entrato
nella testa
avevo tra i 25 ed i 30 anni di ray lane
ho 43 e da quella volta lì in qualche
maniera non sono più stato lo stesso
ve la faccio più o meno breve stavo
facendo qualcosa con le mani un lavoro
manuale non ricordano stava disegnando
e niente
bloccato
avete presente tipo un'intuizione enorme
come se siete lega infatti gli affari
vostri arriva uno
gli apre un libro così due facciate con
una frase è una verità troppo
ingombrante per essere retta ecco poi lo
chiude e se n'era e tu rimani proprio
così con su un precipizio perché è stata
anche ricordo una sensazione fisica
avete presente quando vi danno
un'informazione scomoda bellissima e
bruttissima
quindi c'è proprio una reazione fisica
ok
per open gola brividi
palpitazioni euforia svenimenti c'è pure
chi ci lascia e penn
sono robe serie quella volta io ho
realizzato signore e signori tutto ad un
tratto
che io non ero io che detta così fa un
po ridere ma solo la spiego bene ma non
io non ero io perché sono nato in un
contesto che mi influenza li stimola
influenza sapete nascita in una famiglia
a scegliere un contesto che cittadino
provinciale regionale quando gli usi dei
costumi dei genitori che le parlano la
scuola quello che va moda nei dieci anni
belli dovevi formate dai 6 ai 16
no non sto parlando di questo io sto
parlando che nonostante fosse già
comunque adulto
da quando avevo 18 anni un giorno ho
scelto la mia strada legata alle arti
visive alla per far mingardo teatro una
formazione teatrale formale
io sono sempre stato uno di quelli che
ha pensato pensava di avere militato
fortemente le proprie scelte
no una certa vitalità posso dire anche
oggi una certa anche alcune scelte
radicali di vita proprio nella visione
di quella che può essere la società dal
mio punto di vista è quella volta lì è
arrivata zuccone una legnata allucinante
e poi ieri successo ok io ho quel
secondo lì non sono stato bene per
niente
perché era più del solito e poi era
successo e poi è successo e poi è
successo fino a che ha detto che è qui
io vado lo psicologo ho visto che faccio
l'attore mi diverto e ci mette le mani
ci metto le mani e e quindi ho
cominciato sostanzialmente ad analizzare
la mia vita come le scelte fatte ma
soprattutto quelle non fatte ok quelle
che
sapete ognuno fa le sue che vanno un po
da sole
ho cominciato analizzare tutto perché mi
piace questo tipo di musica ok per
questa ragione perché poi incontrato
quella persona amica di famiglia e
perché mi piace questo perché perché
perché perché perché perché perché
perché sono arrivato
ragionando moltissimo prendendo appunti
studiando sostanza la mente me stesso la
mia esperienza inserita nella società e
negli ambienti che frequentavo io ho una
formazione d'attore poi sono finito a
fare del performer l'artista visivo ma
nella vita ho portato per lavori in
scena personaggi e quelli che poi non si
portano in scena sono di più di quelli
che si porta in scena se qualcuno doveva
fatto teatro avete amici quello che voi
vedete su un palcoscenico alla punta
della iper c'è molto lavoro di solito
un po per questa ragione chiamavano così
deformazione professionale un po chiuso
passarello un po perché comunque c'è
qualcuno che dice che esistono 11
dimensioni in pochissimo spazio cioè
queste cose che prima erano strozzate ok
con l'equazione le stanno dimostrando
quindi
ho cominciato a metterci le mani ho
cominciato a giocare quindi per me non è
stato difficile
sostanzialmente mettere appunto degli
esercizi a scommettere esercizi una
parola grossa diciamo così pratiche ok
che funzionavano come stesso
sostanzialmente è
quello va indietro erano la avanti si va
indietro non sono spaventato pensavo che
ho finito il tempo allora che hanno a
che vedere con la pratica d'attore
quindi per
dimenticarsi di chi si è
io con me stesso ho fatto una serie di
zucchetti che arrivano appunto
dell'esperienza teatrale che però poi ho
messo a punto e ho sperimentato nella
società quindi non protetto da questa
relazione che c'è io sono qua su
comunque lo speaker voi siete pubblico è
tutto chiaro no no no qua io credo che è
tutta una recita
e quando andate a casa recitate quando
andate a lavorare e recitate a casa da
soli recitate finora davanti allo
specchio è uno spettacolone spettacolare
ok è visto come uno spazio proprio
vedere la realtà come un vero e proprio
spettacolo con tutti i personaggi
scritti benissimo e
mi aiuta a sbloccare di meno ecco io
quando cominciano starci più dentro
perché al giorno d'oggi è facile mi
ricordo che stiamo tutti recitando cioè
perché insomma per fare per andare a
lavorare per tutta la vita
un lavoro che dal ti piace se devi
essere un attore con due maroni così o
comunque molto bravo sarà non funziona
solo in funzione
dunque le pratiche sono state tante
quelle dal travestirsi ok io mi vestivo
con un outfit che non era il mio qui
vedo un po sede anche un po fighetti là
in fondo voi lo sapete che cosa vuol
dire non andando in giro con una cosa
che non è del tutto la vostra è un po
scomodi perfetto quando quella cosa la
fate posso proprio vera per gioco io la
facciamo per studio
succedono un sacco di cose a livello
percettivo e a livello della percezione
dell'altro quindi se io un giorno non mi
resto da andrea cambio città e vada farò
da fare un giro va dalla musica vado in
farmacia
pian piano mi rendo conto che gli occhi
che andrea normalmente addosso non sono
più gli stessi quindi andrea è diventato
un andrea diciamo ipotetico che però per
le persone che sera da sembrano lui è
reale a tutti gli effetti
sono per una volta qua a ferrara è
successo mi sono anche vestito da prete
ed è stato molto interessante perche era
venuto da solo io stavo uscendo vestito
di tutto il minero cosa che non faccio
mai praticamente è
effettivamente la manica corta era un po
troppo corta cibavano era un pò troppo
lungo io ero anche allenato volevo il
nero solo che mi vede di bare sono un
prete e quindi steaua prima cosa che me
ne vado a tagliare un pezzo di cartone
bianco dove lo metto qui esco di casa e
osservo semplicemente l'ho fatto qua non
funziona dove avete relazioni questa
pratica ok funziona se ti guardi sono
nuovi e vi scoprono ho incontrato anche
due tre mesi che ovviamente ha capito
che facevo 1 di questa loris messi a
ridere non mi ha neanche salutato
ma è stato molto divertente ma sta molto
divertente vi ripeto io ve lo propongo
come gioco che potete fare con amici
fidanzate cioè voi vi cambiate prendete
un treno andate a parma o dove vi pare a
voi vi cambiata in un bar e uscite e
vedete cosa succede è molto molto
divertente
un altro di questi esercizi e
sforzarsi a mangiare cose che non vi
piacciono
c'è proprio una questione legata a
quella che è stata la cultura del gusto
cioè noi ci piacciono determinate cose
per una serie di ragioni che a volte
sembra in irrazionali cio
non mangiavo le cose marroni mi ricordo
i bambini con il romanzo alle cose verdi
era cosa
strana quindi l'idea era rimettere le
mani in tutti questi frammenti
dell'andrea che mi hanno raccontato che
ho sempre creduto di essere per cercare
di creare il mio standard all'interno di
un'auto standard ok questo tutto
all'interno delle leggi e non è che
si fa il bordello no tutto tutori o una
famiglia un bambino di sei anni
nonostante ciò faccio questi esperimenti
allora un altro ve ne dico un'altra poi
dobbiamo partire che ve lo propongo
addirittura si fa allo specchio al
mattino quando ci si sveglia
venga la delega con è riuscita a tre
spanne dallo specchio due tre spanne vi
guardate nelle pupillo né fino a che
insomma provate a sfogare un po
l'immagine vi ricordate quando in
spiaggia vendevano quelle immagini che
c'era bisogno di puntare al centro e poi
veniva fuori è un'immagine
tridimensionale un pochino il trick è
quello riguardante le pupille fino a che
mandate la vostra immagine un po fuori
fuoco e i bordi del viso
cominciano a deformarsi l'ombra l'ombra
creata dalla luce dello specchio
comincia a modificarli un pochino i
tratti e il bigallo provato con alcuni
amici ovviamente alcune decine di
persone e tutti quanti a un certo punto
dopo meno di mezzo secondo che mettono
fuori fuoco cominciano a non
riconoscersi del tutto diciamo che
cominciano a somigliare a un tipo
somatico
quando lesse vi succede che non vi
riconoscete del tutto vuol dire che
siete sulla strada buona da quel momento
quello che vi entra nella testa lo
lascia tentare poi io normalmente quello
che entra in testa a volte lo scrivo a
volte nello pratico perché è
sostanzialmente è il mio lavoro ecco
l'ultima cosa
algoritmi e genitori vi voglio mollare
con quest'atto nella
genitori cioè due ceffi ho anch'io lo
sono ok che devono dire a uno che non sa
chi è ok che cosa deve fare che cosa si
piazzerà
algoritmi non sono dei sessi sono
dell'operazione che servono per
raggiunto il risultato che
sostanzialmente reggono la nostra vita
di oggi come dicevo il collega prima e
sostanziali decidono per noi di nostri
gusti quindi se io fino a che sono nato
ci sono due che decidono per me ok poi
quando sono adolescente siamo tutti i
grandi quindi i mezzi li abbiamo avuti
giada grandi ma chi adolescente oggi
quando è che ha tempo di capire chi
cazzo è cioè quand'è che sceglie adesso
la butta sul ridere ma è inquietante no
bene io direi che possiamo partire col
brano che abbiamo finito
avete degli anno pianetti dietro le
avete dietro alla poltrona ce ne sono
700 in tutto il teatro
quelli di sotto ne hanno un po di più
per per ragioni di ricircolo ok
vi ricordate quando eravate piccoli no
allora si possono fare degli esperimenti
anche sul se glissato nel tempo quindi
voi nel futuro non ci potete andare ma
nel vostro passato si ok quindi
probabilmente una bella guerra che
l'unica guerra accettabile diciamolo è
quello degli aeroplanini forse non
l'avete fatta tutti ma un oro platino so
che lo avete lanciato tutti allora da
piccoli ragazzi il team non esisteva vi
ricordate che che storia strana
percettiva no
addirittura lo spazio da piccoli e da
piccoli ci sono
45 posti 23 luoghi casa a casa della
nonna
ci sono dei problemi che non è che siano
diversi da quelli che abbiamo j
i problemi sono pochi ma sono enormi
gelato andare dalla nonna
ok sonohra baby tosse
perché poi latitudine nostra idea verso
stronzata una roba da bambini no no no
tutt'altro
allora l'idea era di fare un pochino un
tuffo in quella qualità emotiva e
anarchica di quando si giocano adesso
siamo tutti i grandi l'acs in e quindi è
un'altra cosa però l'idea è quella
seguite la traiettoria del vostro
aeroplano netto nella vita se non
invecchiate le le traiettorie degli
altri e intuizioni non arrivano non
arrivano solo studiando ok non arrivano
solo praticando arrivano entrando nella
vita degli altri e faccende tra le vite
degli altri della propria se no
sennò il tempo non passa più e tutto un
bus di gare qui come dicono a ferrara
pastor chiara cercare di capirci
qualcosa
no allora siete tutti pronti allora io
consiglio di
magari puntare verso il centro le fasce
in platea
se volete tirare verso in auto così
quelli di sopra ve li ritirano di sotto
insomma
se abbiamo tutti sopra evento blocco
tutti carichi ma veramente tutti gli al
pari dell'altro fatemi vedere come i
bimbi dell'asilo
benissimo
allora ciglio anch'io a neo 10
si poi ce ne sono otto alcuni
parcheggiati per per sessioni di cani
casa da qualche parte il basso è
rientrato ci siete dopo volume
543 potete customizzare lì se volete
maschietti che lo so che non si state
dentro
21 via
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]